- So, Sal here at Khan Academy
worldwide headquarters,
and I'm excited to be
here with Barbara Oakley,
who's an expert on learning
and learning how to learn.
And so, Barbara, let me just start
with a question that I'm sure many that
many of Khan Academy users or
young people around the world,
frankly, all people have faced,
which is you're trying to learn something,
and you're looking at a textbook
or a teacher's giving a lecture,
and all of a sudden it's
just not making sense
and you keep trying to
pound your head on it.
What's going on in the brain at that time,
and is the only option to
keep trying to power forward?
- Oooo, the last thing you want to do
is keep powering forward.
I mean, ultimately you want to do that,
but if you're really stuck,
and you're very frustrated,
as I used to get, when
I was trying to study
when I was growing up,
the best thing to do
is to back off and get
your mind completely off
what you're stuck on.
And I mean completely off.
So either study something very different,
or go out for a walk, or just do something
that gets your mind off of it.
As soon as you get your mind off it,
it turns out, that opens up
a completely different set
of neural circuits.
It's the difference between task positive,
where you're focusing, and task negative,
where you're not focusing at all,
and these other, this
alternate set of circuits
is what allows you to begin making sense
of the stuff that you've
been struggling with.
So as long as you're focusing on it,
you're actually keeping yourself stuck,
because you're not allowing
these other neural circuits
to kinda kick into gear.
So that's why people say, back
off when you get frustrated.
I never understood that
before and now I do.
It's very powerful.
- So what you're saying
actually backs up my experience.
I remember in college
when I used to take these,
kind of, very difficult
math proof classes,
and these proofs, the
first time you look at 'em,
I'd be like I don't know,
but I got into a habit,
I kinda fell into it,
of I would read the proofs
and make sure I understood,
or read what I was trying to prove
and make sure I understood it,
and then I would go to sleep,
and then I would wake
up in the next morning,
and it was like I had just
kinda got out of the work,
I had delegated it to my brain.
And it just happened, and you're saying,
that actually is, it's based in science.
- It's based in really good science.
In fact there's some great research out
that shows that as you sleep at night,
that's when those little dendritic spines
will like explode out and make
those synaptic connections.
And it happens when you're sleeping.
So if you've learned, you've studied,
focused during the day,
you go to sleep at night,
that's when the neural architecture
is actually popping out and forming.
So that's why sleep can be
such an important part of learning.
= And how do you know this?
Have y'all actually looked at,
do you have people trying
to learn something,
and then you put 'em in
an MRI, how do you know?
- Well Gwang Yang at NYU has
done some fantastic research
published in science, and
it studies what happens
to neurons when you sleep at night.
And often some of these
studies involve mice
because we don't want to
dissect little living infants
and so forth, for some reason.
And but it's, but it really gives us
a great understanding
of how that architecture
is growing while we sleep.
And there's another thing.
When you go to sleep,
well, during the day,
as the day goes by, you get this sort of
little toxic stuff that's
coming out of your cells.
So that's why at night, you feel kind of
mentally fatigued.
But when you go to sleep, what happens is,
your brain cells shrink.
This allows those, the metabolic,
I mean the sort of cerebral fluids
to wash away those toxins and that's why
in the morning you feel so much fresher.
You don't wanna go a night without sleep
or with a very small amount of sleep,
because that can't wash those toxins away,
and then the next day, you're working
with a poison brain,
which isn't a good idea.
- So making this very tangible.
If I have an exam coming
up, let's say next week,
what would you, based on what you know,
and based on what the science tells us,
what would be the optimal strategy.
And let's just say I don't know much
of what is covered on the
exam in a week from now.
How would you tell me to approach that?
- Don't sit there and
say, I'm gonna do 10 hours
of studying the day before the exam.
Instead, I'm going to take, let's say
you have 10 hours available.
Parse that out, do an hour,
hour and a half each day,
and each day as you learning,
that night when you go to sleep,
you're making some more connections.
The next night, you've studied some,
and you're making more connections.
And as each day goes by, you're building
a really solid set of connections.
If you wait until the
day before and then cram,
you're building very poor connections,
'cause you only have one night of sleep
to actually do the connections with.
- And sometimes, it's even worse.
I remember from college,
what most students do
is actually use that last night of sleep
to study those 10 hours.
And then they go in without
any sleep oftentimes.
Which sounds like the
worst possible thing.
- It is, and then what sometimes happens
is they'll come to me and say,
I suffer from test anxiety.
And actually, test anxiety is very real.
Some people study really hard,
and they get very nervous.
But other people use poor strategies,
and then they freeze on the test,
and it's because they didn't actually
learn the material well.
Because we don't teach about how
the brain learns very much,
that's part of why people
make these kinds of
sometimes tragic mistakes.
- So if this makes sense, and I think,
even before knowing about the science,
a lot of students, all
of us, intuitively know,
yes, I should probably
start working on it sooner.
I shouldn't do it last minute.
So why do we, as humans, do that?
Why do we put it off to the last minute?
- Oh, because when you even
just think about something
you don't like or don't want to do,
it activates the insular cortex,
the portion of the brain
that experiences pain.
So the brain naturally
enough skitters away
from that thought to a new thought
that's like, ooo, this
is so much more fun,
and it'll go surfing the web
or doing whatever's more fun,
and you've just procrastinated.
So a very powerful way of
tackling this kind of thing
is to use something called
the Pomodoro Technique,
that was--
- Pomodoro?
- Pomodoro, and that was
invented by an Italian,
Francesco Cirillo, and
Pomodoro is Italian for tomato.
It's so simple.
What this does is it sneaks your brain
past that tendency to go
away from whatever's painful.
You just set a timer for 25 minutes,
you get rid of anything
that's possibly a distraction.
So no little ringy
dingies on your cell phone
or that kind of thing,
and no popups on your computer,
but then you set that
timer for 25 minutes,
and you focus as intently
as you can for 25 minutes,
realizing that we all, of course,
have these monkey minds,
and you may catch yourself
and have to bring yourself back,
but the most important part,
is when you're done with the 25 minutes,
you relax, you reward
yourself with something.
And what that's doing, is
that's actually allowing you
to get into the diffuse mode,
this more task-negative, relaxing thing
where you're consolidating
what you've just learned.
So this is a big reason why
this technique is so powerful.
- So, and is there something
magic about the 25 minutes?
Why not 15 minutes or 40 minutes?
- Oh, there is, very good question.
So, the magic is that, remember
that pain in the brain?
Well, it goes away after about 20 minutes.
So 25 minutes is that perfect sweet spot
that kind of starts
getting you in the flow,
and you may even find, oh, wait,
I'm at 25 minutes, it says I should stop,
well, sometimes, I'm in the flow,
so I'll just keep right on going.
And that's okay if I go 25, 45, two hours,
whenever, when I do stop, I reward myself,
and that helps program my brain
to enjoy the focusing process even more.
It's like Pavlov with the dogs.
He'd ring a bell and then after a while
the dogs knew they were
gonna get a reward,
so they'd enjoy that time in between.
We're even like that as humans.
We can begin enjoying
that focusing period.
- And so, make sure I understand,
it's not that you have
to stop at 25 minutes.
It's just that at 25
minutes, the bell rings,
you have earned the right for guilt-free
whatever it might be.
- Bingo.
- Surfing the web,
go for a walk, and that even
that time is still productive.
You shouldn't have guilt
associated with it.
One, you did your focused time,
but you're also saying
you're getting into this,
the default mode is how you described it,
and that's where your
brain, if you go for a walk,
you're starting to form the connections
based on what you just focused.
- That's right, and we often think
that if you're relaxing
and you're not focusing,
that you're not doing any work.
But actually, your brain is doing a lot
of productive, yet subconscious, work
when you're taking these breaks.
Which is part of why these
breaks are so important.
And they also, if you focus,
focus, focus all the time,
there is some evidence
that it might actually
reduce your creativity, reduce the ability
of the default mode to
kind of kick into play.
So when you're taking these little breaks,
you're actually also sort of
encouraging your creativity.
- And when the bell rings
but you're in your flow,
and if you're getting,
if you're feeling like
this is really good, and the pain,
I mean, that is
fascinating, it's literally,
'cause I don't feel physical pain.
There's all sorts of things,
I'm procrastinating at
least 20 things right now.
And I'll, I don't feel pain,
but it's triggering the
same part of the brain.
- Well, everybody procrastinates,
because when you're working on one thing
you're not working on another thing.
But you're a little bit, different,
to use as a model case
for procrastination,
because you don't think
like a lot of people do.
But for me--
- Probably a good thing.
- But a lot of times you can get really,
you can have a lot of good
things, good options on the table
and then you may not feel
that pain in the brain.
For me, usually there's something,
I'll have this thing I wanna work on,
this thing, this thing, this thing,
and I'll work happily away,
and there's this one thing,
and I've been putting it off,
and that's the one that can kick in
that pain in the brain sort of feeling.
- And it's really, I mean,
you definitely avoid it,
and it's like a subconscious pain almost.
For just that point about this,
I'm fascinated by this, the Pomodoro,
and the timer, if you're
feeling in the flow.
You don't have to stop.
You can keep going.
- Yes, and what I'll often do,
is I have a little timer on my computer,
I'm using it, I'm working
away maybe on something,
and I don't have my sound
turned on on the computer.
So I can always just go check and see,
oh, has it expired or not?
But it doesn't actually
kick me out and say,
check, do you wanna quit now?
I can just decide that when I feel free.
But there's a lot of great apps
using the Pomodoro Technique,
so people like to use these
apps a lot of the time,
and they'll collect Pomodoros.
So Forest is a very popular app,
and if you complete a
Pomodoro, you plant a tree.
If you don't, you kill a tree.
But you can collect like
two to three Pomodoros
on a certain topic, another
number on another topic,
if you like, if you're sort of,
if that helps your productivity,
it's a great approach.
For me, I generally just love to work,
so I'm working away, but occasionally,
I will find myself surfing the web,
and there's this one
thing I should be doing.
So I'll set the timer and I'll get going
with the Pomodoro, and I can feel it now.
My brain is trained.
As soon as I set that timer,
I start kind of working away
and actually getting excited
about even stuff I don't like.
It's a great technique.
- And there might be skeptics out there,
says, okay, Professor
Oakley, she's saying it,
but she's a fancy professor.
You said, you know, my brain
might be wired differently,
but they might say, your brain is probably
wired differently.
You're a professor.
You've done, has this
always, how has learning
been for you most of your life?
- Well, before I talk about that,
I should mention, so I
teach a very large course
called Learning How to Learn
with Terry Sejnowski on learning,
and I have to say that out of
two and a half million students,
it almost seems sometimes
like I've heard from them all
and they love the Pomodoro Technique.
So it is, I've just
gotten a lot of feedback,
and it really helps for everybody,
not just people like me.
But people like me, well,
my own background is
I hated math and science
when I was growing up.
I flunked my way through
elementary, middle,
and high school math and science.
I just didn't have the math gene,
knew I couldn't do it.
And then when I was 26 years old,
I was getting out of the military,
and you know, for some weird reason,
nobody wanted to get me
with my Slavic languages
and literature degree, and I thought,
maybe I should see if I
can learn something new,
like maybe even this math stuff.
Because I could see the
officers I'd worked with,
they had great job opportunities,
they were often West Point engineers,
and so I started, and see,
I wish there had been
Kahn Academy back then,
but I started with remedial
high school algebra
and started working my way
up, and now, and it worked.
I'm a professor of engineering.
But if you use some of
these ideas about learning,
I've found that the way I learned Russian
at the Defense Language Institute
is actually very similar to how you learn
in math and science, and when I applied
those same techniques, which
are actually the techniques
that involve how your brain
really learns, it worked.
But if I'd known then what I know now
about learning, I still
could've made it much easier.
- So after the military, you went on this
wanting to go back into math.
But at that time, you did not
know about these techniques.
You just, what was different about it
when you were learning it in your 20s
versus when you first tried to learn it
when you were 14 or 15.
- I didn't have to have
a job when I was 14 or 15
because I was supported by my parents.
Yeah, I lived in that home.
- So there was an urgency to it.
There was a high stakes.
- And I think part of it, too,
is I looked at the future, and I thought,
you know, we know language and culture
is always gonna be really important,
but in today's world, math and science
is really important as well.
And it's not like you
have to become an engineer
or a computer scientist, but
if you have some knowledge
of those fields, it really
broadens your ability
to get decent jobs today.
So I always say, I did the
thing everybody told me,
I followed my passion.
I learned a language.
But I didn't broaden my passion.
And that left me in a box.
And so today, I often encourage people,
it's great to follow your passion,
but broaden it also, and
you'll find that it's
really helpful in today's working world.
- And how did you, so
you went back into math,
motivated, to some degree, by economics,
and you, it seems like you learned it.
How did you fall into
this area of research?
When you went back to grad school,
did you say, I want, this
learning is interesting to me
because it, there's a phase in my life
where I had trouble and
now I figured it out?
Or did you, how did you get to this field,
which is a fascinating one?
I think it applies to everyone.
What was the trigger
that got you interested?
- Oh, good question.
So I did kind of just dink
around a lot in my life.
I mean, I was in the military as enlisted
and an officer, I worked
at the South Pole Station
in Antarctica--
- [Sal] Wouldn't categorize
that as dinking around.
That seems, that's kind of
hard core dinking, I guess.
- Yes, hard core.
- That's quite
impressive dinking.
(audience laughter)
- And I used to work as a translator
for the Russians on Soviet
trawlers up in the Bering Sea.
But in all of these kinds of things,
now, see, there's one problem, though.
See, I'm not like you.
You have this incredible working memory.
My working memory is
like one thing at a time,
and when get on, I get
it, and it's like, so,
Ooo, it's shiny, and
then I get distracted--
- [Sal] We are more
similar than you imagine.
- So what was the question again?
- For real?
- For real.
(audience laughter)
- Oh, yeah, no, that's,
I thought that was,
how did you get interested?
Maybe I do have slightly
longer working memory,
if that was for real.
But how did you get
interested in this field?
- The thing is, I, well,
it just, a student asked
a question, and said,
he found out, 'cause I was
just a typical professor,
maybe with a little bit
lower working memory
than many professors,
but I did my engineering
research and so forth.
And one day, but I loved to write.
And so on the side, I'd write,
but I'd keep it hidden because tenure,
and all that kind of stuff.
So one day a student asked me,
he found out I was terrible
at math growing up,
and said, you know, how'd you do it?
How'd you change your brain?
And I thought, how did I change my brain?
And so I wrote him a little email,
and then I thought, well,
because of the past books
I'd written, I knew a
little about neuroscience,
about cognitive psychology.
And I thought, well, I should put together
some of these ideas,
because a lot of information
that's out there on learning
comes from education
or some from the field
of cognitive psychology,
but there's actually all
this incredible research
that's being done in the
field of neuroscience.
And so I put together a manuscript,
and that became the
book, A Mind for Numbers.
I just kinda wrote a book about it
and it turned out really super popular,
and so I was just surprised.
'Cause it was kind of a
little side venture for me
because I just thought I was gonna do
my normal engineering stuff,
and then people really liked it.
It was a very fresh approach,
I think, to learning
that brought in, a lot of times,
what, there's great, great information
about how to learn effectively,
but it really only
encompasses a small portion
of what is truly needed to
know how to learn effectively.
So, for example, you
find these great books
in cognitive psychology
and they don't even mention
that procrastination
is the number one issue
for students and how do you tackle that?
And there's just so much information
that's not being put together,
and so I like to synthesize
and stand on the shoulders
of these great researchers, but bring in
a lot of different ideas, and so that's,
I just kind of backed
into it accidentally.
- 'Cause it is fascinating,
'cause there is
all this research going on that I actually
had no idea about until starting to look
at some of your work,
and it is so practical,
and it so relevant to frankly everyone,
but no one was really communicating,
or maybe, communicating
it in the right way.
Why isn't this part of, why
doesn't every orientation
at every school and college and workplace
start off with these techniques?
'Cause it seems like,
it's not just school,
it seems like even in
the workplace, you know,
there's I gotta get that memo
out to my coworker by Wednesday.
I go, I'll do it Tuesday night.
Why isn't this more
widespread in your sense?
- I think that it's, it's really only
in the last 10 years or so
that we have gotten a good understanding
of how the brain works,
or a better understanding.
There's still a long way to go.
And it hasn't caught up
with modern pedagogy,
and so if you asked,
let's say you ask someone
to create an online course on
how do you learn effectively,
or you ask some university,
a major university,
to produce such a course.
They'd say great, we'll
do it for teachers.
And if you said, no,
actually, normal people,
ordinary people would
like to know this, too.
They'd say, good, we'll produce a course
and it will have two weeks
on the history of education,
two more weeks on theories of education,
two more weeks on how babies learn,
a little bit on how people learn,
but no neuroscience,
maybe just one lecture,
'cause it's too hard.
So what Terry and I did was kind of flip
that all on its head and say,
well, let's start from neuroscience.
If it's too advanced,
we'll use some metaphors
to help bring you along.
And it actually is easy stuff,
and it's so useful, and that's why
the Learning How to Learn
course is so incredibly popular.
It's simple and easy kinds of information,
but I think some of it, too,
is let's say you are a professor
of cognitive psychology
and you've just spent the
last 30 years of your life
researching issues
related to working memory,
you know, there's part
of you that screams,
well, it can't be that easy.
You know, I've been working
forever on this thing
and she's making it just like,
but it actually is, the fundamental ideas
are really, really easy
for anybody to understand.
And so, I've been working with Terry
and Greg Hammons to make some
great videos for kids now
that also explain some of these ideas,
because everybody says,
these ideas about learning
are so simple that anybody can learn 'em.
I wish I had known them when I was a kid.
Actually, that's true, so that's what
we've been working on.
- Yeah, it's so surprising, because one,
they seem, they make intuitive sense,
but then when you back it up
with the neuroscience, then it...
Are there skeptics here?
It feels like you could
say the sky is blue
and there'll be skeptics.
There'll be someone who will say,
are there people who say, well, no,
that's not exactly right,
sometimes it's better to pull
an all-nighter, I don't know.
Are you hearing push back from anyone?
- No, I mean, every great
once in a while, you get,
anybody will get push back.
But, when you're working with
one of the world's
greatest neuroscientists,
all I kinda have to do is say,
okay, you wanna argue
about the neuroscience?
Go talk to this guy.
And Terry is really one
of the world leaders.
I think if you use a metaphorical approach
to explain some of
these fundamental ideas,
and you say, I'm using a
metaphor, this is the main idea,
it's kind of hard to argue with that.
- And going back to the
very practical tips,
I guess you could say.
We talk about the importance of sleep.
Would you say that it's,
is there any research,
or even rules of thumb, about
maybe the best time to study?
Morning, evening, or is that kind of,
the jury's out on that?
- Jury's out, because some people,
some people are morning
people, others are night owls.
They find that as the day goes by,
you're metabolites will come out
and you're getting, accumulating toxins,
but even so, some people
just seem to be able
to perform better at night.
And so, you know, bless 'em.
I wish I could be that way.
But there's just, everyone's different.
We do find that there's
about four hours or so
of really intense time you
can do deliberate practice
and do something that's really hard.
So, for example, if
you're a concert pianist,
about four hours is
your best practice time,
or mathematician, whatever.
But you can still get a lot done.
Sleep, though, there do
seem to be a few people
that have this short sleep gene
that can get by on three
or four hours of sleep,
I want that gene.
Can they maybe introduce it somehow?
But for most people, you need
around eight hours or so.
Younger people need more sleep.
Naps can help, but they
can't really replace
a good solid block of sleep at night.
- It's interesting as
connected to Khan Academy,
this four hour number that you mentioned,
it definitely syncs with
my person experience.
'Cause when I make videos,
videos are actually
quite mentally taxing to do,
because most of them,
they're done in real time.
So you're trying to do
the problem in real time,
but at the same time
there's a part of your brain
that's making sure, are you
saying all the right things?
Will this be understandable for someone?
Are you speaking cohesive, you know,
all of these types of things.
Since I've started this
journey on Kahn Academy,
about four hours is my cap.
After four hours, I
really can't produce more,
and then I try to do less
mentally intensive things.
But it is amazing, I kind of just
hit a wall after four hours.
- Yeah, I find that myself.
And so people say, well,
then we should only have
four hours in the workday.
I wish, but actually, four
hours of really intense,
and then the other hours as,
you can still be very
productive, just doing things
that are a little less
intellectually demanding.
- And my old boss, and I didn't realize,
his advice was based
in sound neuroscience,
but even when I worked at the hedge fund,
finance and hedge funds
are normally associated
with people working 80 hours a week,
and always on and all this,
he was very adamant that as
soon as the markets closed
at, you know were were in Boston, at 4:30,
when we were out in
California, it was at 1:30,
he'd say, go home, recharge,
make sure you get a night's sleep,
because our whole job is
to make good decisions
and to avoid bad ones, and as soon as you,
but I think he's also
implicitly saying that,
look, you've been studying
all of these stocks
and doing all of this analysis all day.
Part of it is let those, let
that default mode happen.
- That's right.
- And so you might start
seeing some insights.
- I think that's very true.
It's very good advice.
I think another piece
of advice that I give,
and I don't know that there's actually
neuroscience based on this,
is to try, during your recharge hours,
to learn about something
that's completely unrelated
to whatever your main task is.
And I think what that
does is that allows you
to think more creatively.
Let's say that you're trying
to really learn about investing.
So you read all the books about investing.
But you're actually
reading all the same books
about investing that
everybody else is reading.
If you are learning something
completely different,
just a tiny bit of the time,
you will bring, through,
metaphor and analogy,
creative new ideas and new approaches
to whatever you're learning about.
- That's fascinating, 'cause I sometimes,
you see this pattern in people's lives
that when they're school-aged,
they're studying multiple subjects,
but then as soon as they get
into their field of specialty,
they start only reading or doing
in that field of specialty,
and what you're suggesting,
and it does seem right, I am curious,
maybe someone will do
research on this eventually,
that you might be doing
yourself the best service,
do that four hours, maybe do three hours
of the thing that you have
to do in the next week
or whatever, in the next year,
but then maybe give yourself some time
to do something completely different
and don't feel bad about it.
It might actually be forming connections
that you don't even appreciate.
- That's exactly right,
I couldn't agree more.
- Well, I have many more questions,
but I wanna open it up to
those of y'all in the audience.
Any questions?
Yes, Julia.
- [Julia] Can you talk about how you learn
during the course of your life?
Like they say, a young
child can learn a language,
and after a certain age,
you can't really develop
the same language skills.
When you get older, your
brain starts to slow down.
Is there truth to that?
- And repeat the question, just for folks.
- So, does your brain slow
down when you're older,
and can you still learn
languages and so forth?
And the answer is, yeah,
there's a little evidence
that you slow down, and part of the reason
that you slow down is that you
have so many more connections
that it's kind of hard to
do the search and accessing
of what you're trying to
remember and learn and so forth.
It is, there's only a certain window
when you can learn a language
with an appropriate accent.
But you can still learn a language.
In fact, there is plenty of examples,
there's a whole language learner ecosystem
with some terrific individuals,
Benny the Irish Polyglot,
for example, who will
introduce you to people
who are even in their 60s and 70s
and are learning new languages.
But have you ever met those kinds of,
really, they're older people,
and they're kind of curmudgeons,
and they think their way
is right, no matter what?
You don't want to be like that person.
So the best way to avoid
that is to keep your,
keep learning, keep your
mind open to new things,
and so I think these
are the kinds of things
you make available to
everyone in a way that,
whatever level you're
at, you can start there,
and then move upwards
in so many different...
I have to admit, I used your videos
to help improve my statistics course,
because you had such a great approach
for kind of weaving in different ideas
about poisson and binomial
and how they're related.
And then my younger daughter said,
the reason I passed calculus,
and she did very well,
was because of Kahn Academy's videos.
So, you've done some great work.
- Thank you, I'm
flattered, and team effort,
and you're making a brown man
blush, so congratulations.
No, but look, I will also
admit, I also use Kahn Academy,
'cause I think my working memory
is shorter than you give
me credit for, but--
- No, no.
- It is, everyone has
to relearn and review.
And I actually met a Nobel
prize winner in economics
who said that he was using
the Kahn Academy videos
to refresh on certain parts of economics,
because he had gotten so
deep in his specialty,
that when he had to review some more
of the basic ideas, it
was a good refresher.
So there's no shame, no shame in that.
- That's right, I think that's what I love
about the Kahn Academy approach,
is that when you have those gaps,
and everybody's got those gaps,
if you are climbing
higher in that particular
subject matter, you can
go and fill in those gaps
so much more easily with the
videos that are available.
- And we have thousands
of practice items, too,
just my little plug.
But yes, that's, they
can test their knowledge.
Yes, Irene.
- [Irene] Could you share more about what
are some of the concepts behind
the Learning How to Learn?
- Okay, so we've talked
about focused and diffuse,
and then there's also, and
the Pomodoro Technique,
creating sets of links, of neural links,
and practicing with those
sets of neural links
so that you build stronger sets.
What that does, is, see what hap--
- Give an example of that.
What does it mean to practice
with sets of neural links?
- Okay, so I'll give, so for example,
when our younger daughter was
learning to back up the car,
she was, I mean, it was
really, really hard for her.
I mean, it is hard for anybody.
Do you look in the front mirror?
Do you look in the side mirrors?
Do you look behind you?
Which way do you go, and
then you're off in the ditch.
So, what is happening, is
you have a very limited
working memory that can hold usually
a maximum of around four items.
And so, what, you're trying to hold all
these concepts at once,
and it's difficult.
But once you have
learned to back up a car,
so you've learned it,
you've practiced with it,
you really know it, what you've done is
you've kind of parked this
new set of long-term links,
or of links in your long-term memory.
And what's happening
with your working memory
is it's going, oh, I
wanna back up the car.
Well, I've only got four
arms that I can work with.
Well, I already know how to do this,
so I'm just gonna reach
out to this subroutine
that I've parked out in long-term memory.
I'll grab that, pull that
into my working memory,
and oh, yes, while I'm doing that,
my other arms of my
attentional octopus are free
so I can be listening to the radio,
maybe checking to see if
my seatbelt is fastened,
and this is what happens
in a lot of learning.
If you have practiced and created
this nice set of neural links,
then what happens is when
you're taking a test,
you take the test and you
go, well, now wait a minute.
Now, they're wanting me to
put a binomial distribution
together with a geometric,
they're being a little tricky here,
but you can haul them both
up into working memory
because you've got these nice
sort of procedural fluency,
sets of links you've already set up,
so you can just connect 'em in the limited
working memory that you do have.
So the more you, experts
are, they're differentiated
from normal, non-experts by the fact
that they have all sorts
of sets of neural links
that they've created and
parked in long-term memory,
and they can access 'em and bring 'em
up into working memory
whenever they want to.
And so, that is such an
important part of learning.
We often just think, well,
you should conceptually
understand this idea, so
you should pull it all
into working memory and
really have it all in mind,
but our working memory's
really restricted.
You can't have it all in mind.
So you wanna have practiced enough
so that important parts
of what you're learning
are already parked down
in your long-term memory.
And this is, let's say you're learning
to play a musical instrument.
So you learn a chord.
And then you get that
parked in long-term memory.
Now you connect that
up with another chord,
and maybe another, and then suddenly,
you can play part of a song.
And if you practice enough,
you can just get it started
and it'll play on its own.
Actually, that's another story.
But, same for learning a language.
If you're learning, and you practice
with a different conjugation,
verb conjugations,
it becomes very natural, very automatic,
and so, really, the important,
a really important part of learning
is creating these nice sets
of long-term memory links
that you can just instantly
pull into working memory
whenever you need to.
- So would those by kind
of the headline concepts
that you talk about.
So there's the focused and the default...
- Uh, default mode network.
Sometimes I call it diffuse network.
- So focused and diffuse.
- Right.
- The Pomodoro, and then this idea of
getting things, I liked
that, kind of these
mental tentacles, the extra
arms that we can build
through practice by
reinforcing those networks
as much as we can.
- Right, so working memories
are your prefrontal cortex,
and it can connect in to
the long-term sets of links
that you've created there.
So that's another really important thing.
If, so here's, often,
we think that students
best traits are really bad traits.
And what I mean by this,
is sometimes we'll think,
oh, well, you've got
a poor working memory.
That's really bad.
But actually, I am here to tell you,
and it's not just self-justification,
that having a poor working memory
can actually be a really good thing.
And the reason for that is,
remember those four arms
of that attentional octopus
in your working memory,
well, some people are just,
they have really retentive
working memories.
And other people are
a little more like me,
you know, they got it, it's all in my,
oooo, shiny, and then
it's, something falls out.
But when something falls
out, something else comes in,
and research has shown
that individuals that have
problems with their working
memory are often very creative.
And, indeed, my hero in science is a man
named Santiago Ramn y Cajal,
and Cajal was a terrible
student, awful working memory,
couldn't really retain stuff very easily,
was a troubled student,
got kicked out of school
several times, and ended
up winning the Nobel Prize
and is now considered the
father of modern neuroscience.
And Cajal was once asked, how'd you do it?
What's your secret that can help us?
And he said, I am no genius.
And he wasn't, he really struggled
to try to learn something new.
But he said, I was successful
because I was persistent,
and I was flexible when the
data told me I was wrong.
He said, I've worked with many geniuses,
and the challenge with
geniuses is they can be
so smart that they get
used to always being right.
And then, in adult life, they can tend to
jump to conclusions without
having all the data,
and when they're wrong, they
aren't used to being wrong
so they can't change their mind.
Instead, they'll use their
considerable intellect
to justify whatever they've been wrong at.
So, I think the real point here is,
if you're one of those slower thinkers
that really kind of has to
struggle, congratulations.
You can sometimes do things
even geniuses cannot.
- And that makes you question
the whole title of genius,
'cause obviously, by most definitions,
the gentleman you just spoke of would be,
but it's just not in the traditional,
you know, he can't memorize dictionaries
or whatever else, but clearly,
he made insights that
weren't available to others.
And that flexibility is a form
of genius in and of itself.
- I think so, yes.
- Other questions, yes.
- [Woman] Hi, Barb.
I notice you sprinkle a
lot of humor in your videos
and I was wondering if
you could say a few words
about the role of humor in learning.
- Oh, so, the challenge for
me is I'm not very funny,
so I like to have to
script it so carefully
because it just doesn't
necessarily come naturally.
This one fifth grader
was taking our course,
and she said, I never understood
that professors could be so witty.
And I'm like I scripted that witty in!
(audience laughter)
- [Sal] Reading a script right now.
- No, I've just prepared
that very carefully.
But humor--
- I was making the point
that you're overly self-deprecating.
You clearly are witty without a script.
But I'll let you continue your story.
- Wow, I've heard it from the maestro.
But I think that people, a lot of times
university professors,
it is hard to be funny.
I mean, some people are funny naturally,
and that's the way they are,
but a lot of people, it
doesn't come naturally,
and so it's not something that they,
when they're teaching, they would prefer
to just teach the topic and not also have
to worry about humor.
And you can understand that.
But the online world, I think of it as
a mixture of academia with
Silicon Valley with Hollywood,
and if you're gonna be really competitive
in the online world, it's
not like universities,
it's not like grandma's
university anymore,
it's something that you've
gotta be competitive
with everything else
that's going out there
if you have quality material.
And if you have a course that's just
a staid presentation of the material
versus a course that
presents the same material
but it's got some nice humor in it,
people are gonna pick the
funny course every time.
So I think that simply hasn't
received enough attention
from research and MOOC makers,
and I think it's such an, being funny,
even when it's hard, is important,
because it helps people to connect
with who the instructor
is and to have more fun
with the material just as
the instructor is doing.
- The point you're bringing
is an interesting one,
because you're kind of
making market-based argument,
that people will be drawn
to the funnier courses,
but I do suspect that, I'm
curious if neuroscience
has even come up with anything,
or it should be an area of study,
the intuition would be, if people are able
to laugh a little bit,
it de-stresses them,
it opens their mind up so
that they're less likely
to be stressed as the new
information's coming in,
which is actually, might
lead to better learning.
But it is interesting.
Humor is such a big thing in our society,
it's such a big thing of what makes us us,
but it doesn't seem to be that studied.
- It's not.
There's a very good paper,
I believe from 2015,
that's a meta-analysis of humor studies.
And actually, it kind of
concluded the verdict is out
as to whether humor is helpful,
and I think part of that is
- [Sal] Sounds like a
very non-funny study.
(audience laughter
Not much fun to read.
- Well, actually, it had
some funny stuff in there.
I was impressed with it.
But it, one of the things I think they,
they make the mistake of
looking at a particular topic
and saying, okay, we've
got five minutes of funny
and five minutes of non-funny,
a little bit of humor, no humor.
But that's the wrong way to look at humor.
You can't dissect it into a topic.
It's a course.
Does it uplift people's
affect through the course,
and that really has not been studied.
- And attitude, it's a total,
and I wonder, I know we're
going a little off-topic,
but just form an evolutionary
biology point of view,
where humor and laughing, it's funny,
'cause an alien might be afraid
if we're baring our teeth
and we're going ha ha ha,
you know, it almost seems threatening,
but we view it as a, somehow,
it's crept into who we are
as organisms, and it seems to be at least
some of our related organisms, at least,
seem to relate to it.
But it is fascinating.
- It is, I should say,
there's been a little bit
of research on full courses and so forth,
but there's a lot, from a
neuroscientific perspective,
there's a lot of similarity between
that a-ha, creative insight, and the ah,
you're starting to laugh about something.
There's a lot of neuro overlap there.
So I think you're right when you say
that it relaxes people,
and we tend to think
of default mode network as only arising,
like, when you take a few
minutes, a break, and so forth.
But actually default
mode network can arise
just momentarily, even when you blink.
In fact, martial arts experts
like to launch attacks
when you blink, not
because you're not looking,
so much as your brain is
temporarily disconnected
from the outside world and
you go into default mode
during that blink.
And so then, even when you're, I think,
when you're learning
something and you take
that tiny a-ha, laughing break,
my suspicion, and I haven't
seen research evidence
to this effect, is you
temporarily go into default mode,
and it is, it's, you're able to come back
and look at things with a
fresh perspective as a result.
- I now understand why
my offensive charges
in the past weren't as successful.
I timed them wrong.
Other questions?
- [Man] I think we have some questions
over here from students.
- Yeah, Tristan.
- [Tristan] One of the
main problems I have
is that I'm not good at starting something
that I don't like to do, such as math.
Do you have any advice
on starting something
you just haven't been able to start before
because you think it's gonna
take a really long time.
- Oh, that, I so sympathize with you,
because I hated math for so long.
And the thing for me, is you hate a topic
until you start getting traction with it.
You get better at it.
And math can take a little
while to get better at.
So I just go the completely different way.
I'm like, use the Pomodoro Technique.
It means a tiny bit of
something you don't like.
25 minutes is, in the
greater scheme of things,
anybody can do 25 minutes.
So when you're sitting
down, don't sit there
and go, I'm gonna do my math.
And what that's doing
is activating the pain.
Say, I'm sitting down to do a Pomodoro.
And that tricks your brain so you don't
experience the pain quite so much,
and then, oh, I gotta do my 25 minutes.
Now, if you're like me, I
will sit there sometimes,
and something I don't wanna do,
I really work, I set the
timer, I'm on the Pomodoro,
I'm working away, and I
can't help, I look up,
'cause I'm kind of proud of
myself, how much work I've done,
and I've just done two
minutes of the Pomodoro.
And my mind screams, I
can't do 23 more minutes!
But, then I just do the zen thing.
I let that thought flow right on by,
and I continue working for the 25.
And then I give myself a nice reward.
I maybe listen to my favorite song.
Go do a computer game.
Whatever you want to do.
And I think if you try this approach,
it might be very helpful for you.
- Grishawn?
- [Grishawn] Yeah, so as a
student, I don't always like
get to decide when my classes
are, when my breaks are.
So how can I really implement
the Pomodoro Technique
when I'm in my classes or in my goal time,
trying to get work done?
- Oh, okay, so the Pomodoro Technique
kind of presumes that you've
got 25 minutes available
to do that and you block
everything else out.
So what you wanna do is,
if you have self-directed time available,
whatever that time is, just
put away all distractions,
and try to work with as
much focus as you can
on that topic during that
time that you have available.
25 minutes is great, it's
kind of optimal in a way,
but whatever you do have.
One of the core ideas of the Pomodoro
is to not allow yourself to be distracted
by other things, because if,
let's say you're listening
to songs with music in it.
It can be okay to listen to music
as long as it's not loud,
and as long as it doesn't
have lyrics in it.
If it has someone singing, your,
part of your working memory
is gonna be following
along with those words,
and if you're doing something,
writing, in writing,
or you're reading
something, it can interfere,
because you've got that
limited working memory.
So it's a really good thing to just
do the Pomodoro, or do
that period of time,
and try to block everything
out that you can.
Don't be switching tasks.
In other words, oh, I'm
doing this for two minutes,
oh, now I've gotta do this,
oh, and I'm doing this.
Sometimes you'll have to
because of what's being taught,
but as much as you can,
try to keep your focus
'cause the longer you're on there,
the deeper, it's like you're
building these networks,
this connection, you're
bringing it all to mind,
and you wanna just keep
that without multitasking.
'Cause if you're going to another task,
it's like you're ripping
out of those neurons,
and now you're going to
another set of neurons,
and then you've gotta go back to that set
of original neurons and
that can be really tiring.
So hopefully this might help.
- Is there a, we talk
about the 25 minutes.
We don't wanna get too prescriptive,
but is there a sense of
how long the diffuse time,
is there a ratio that
people think is good?
- This is not studied enough.
What I just hear anecdotally is,
if you have a fair bit of work to do,
then maybe five to 10
minutes, something like that.
If you have trouble getting
yourself back on task
after you're taking a break,
set a timer for the break.
Some people like to have a timer
that's a ticking timer when
they're doing their Pomodoro
because it helps remind
them to keep on task.
For me, I like silence when I'm doing it.
But five to 10 minutes,
and then after you've done
several in row, then maybe
take a 15 minute break.
- 25 minutes on, five to 10 minutes off.
It would speak to Grishawn's question,
you know, we have a lab school downstairs,
and one of the goals
of it is to think about
what school should be like.
And so even this technique,
and we already have
a principle around as much
active learning as possible
versus passive learning, but
even that active learning,
we might have to get
everyone timers or something
to think about how to do this,
followed by maybe 10, 15 minutes breaks
could be interesting.
- And I had to point out, when
it comes to active learning,
there's a large
meta-analysis that was done
of STEM learning, and what they found was
that one in three students would
drop out of STEM programs,
science, technology,
engineering, and math,
if it was just the traditionally taught.
But only one in five would drop out
if it was active learning.
And part of what's
going on, I think of it,
and I think there's some truth to this,
is when you're active learning,
you're not not just
passively watching someone.
You are, in some sense,
like here's your dendrite
on your neuron, you are almost
pulling a dendritic spine
to start coming out and
making a little connection.
And that's what active,
that's almost, I think,
and maybe studies will
show this, we'll see,
but that's almost why
when you're really working
on something hard with
deliberate practice,
it almost hurts.
So I can relate this to why I
cannot play the piano today.
So when my parents wanted
me to play the piano,
so I found out, though,
I was not a dumb kid,
I found out that as
long as you were hearing
music come out, they didn't
mind whatever I was doing.
So I learned a song,
and I played that song
over and over, I put a comic book up,
and I could just play
that song over and over
for an hour while I was
reading my comic book,
and I could read my comic book--
- [Sal] That's actually quite impressive.
- If you learn a song really well,
but did I advance in my studies?
No, I didn't, because I wasn't
doing deliberate practice.
I wasn't pushing myself beyond,
and so that is the essence
of why deliberate practice,
kind of focusing on the harder stuff--
- A little bit out of your comfort zone,
stretching a little bit,
zone of proximal development,
Goldilocks zone, whatever people call it.
You did not do that.
- I did not do that, and
now I cannot play the piano.
- You do many other things very well.
Other, maybe, we have time
for one or two more questions.
Yeah?
- [Woman] I had a quick question.
There's this phrase,
it's like riding a bike.
And something that you
haven't done for a while,
but have learned, you might be able
to pick that up very quickly.
That doesn't seem to be
the case for all things
that one learns, so I was wondering
is it to do with the
learning, the activity type,
or what is it to actually
increase retention
of things that you've already learned?
- That's a very good question.
From an evolutionary perspective,
we think of what we learn, it actually,
there's two different types
of things that we learn.
And one is like evolutionarily primary,
and that is things like learning
to speak a language and so forth.
Well, evolutionarily secondary learning
are things like learning to read,
learning how to write, and
learning how to do math.
Those come with more difficulty.
And that is why, a lot of times teachers,
with great intent, will say,
oh, learning should always be as fun,
in high school as it was
when you were a little kid,
a baby, and so forth.
Well, that's when you were learning things
that came naturally to human beings,
like speaking a language,
your native language.
And so, I think that when
you're learning something,
it depends a lot on whether it's a primary
or a secondary type of learning thing.
And it also depends, there's a,
it's a really complicated subject.
So for example, if I try
to learn Spanish now,
I learned Russian before,
and it will come out sometimes in Russian
whether I like it or not,
and if I have a little bit
of vodka, the Russian comes
back even more easily...
- [Sal] Vodka, in particular.
- Vodka, in particular,
vodka from the freezer.
Properly stored,
- We're not advocating
anything...
- It's in the freezer.
(audience laughter)
That's for sure.
But it is funny how the environmental cues
that you had can also be helpful.
- And so, unfortunately, I
think we're all out of time.
But thank you so much for this.
I think for everyone watching,
for all of us here at Khan Academy,
I think, personally, we're all
gonna maybe get some timers
or use some of these apps,
but I think it really does,
it is very tangibly useful
to have some of these frameworks.
And I think as we think
about Khan Academy,
even the product and the experience,
as we think about how we
do practice on Khan Academy
and all of these things,
I think it will be very
valuable for us to say,
maybe some of these ideas that we learned
from Professor Oakley will be,
could make a big difference here.
So thank you so much,
and for any of y'all are interested,
do a web search for
Professor Barbara Oakley.
You'll see all sorts
of interesting things.
(audience applause)